vamos buscar a volta agora no japão
o gato tudo pessoal aqui quem fala é dar
que sejam muito bem vindos
é mais um melhor do que o que é isso
quem isto escriturais turma o xvii e se
estreou em jogos no rio
acho que fazia eu efe tai do um reputado
como vocês podem ver que sua loja minha
namorada está aqui em carmona é completo
por exemplo buscar o colega então fish
mas eu só pessoal bucco neon abrir sobre
sabores mogi chegou já está gasto porque
foi um bom me madrid que olhem que o com
uma bolinha preencher
eu nem o globo não funciona a morena
agora eu acho que esse instrumento não
eu sei fazer o é sempre que ficar um bom
tempo que eu tenho eu de silvino batalha
uma batalha superintência segue não é um
deles estão dentro tipos que isso só
sabiam que conectará a namorada está
quase a sair ainda não foi gravado mas
estamos com essa desgraça que o slogan
poderes parece muito mais por vir
ae mas mais mas faz boa rumo
vocês não funciona ali perto e se sentiu
o gol e pelo ku que que o pt quer só já
fica tudo escuro só se quiserem que como
evitar uma namorada dois não só come se
fica por aí
[Aplausos]
[Música]
sou eu e mônica que vamos fazer agora
nós agora um mandato obama para fora e
eu não podem porque agora eu vou fazer
uma coisa que eu que sempre fazer o que
né não
bur é fácil embora muitos não é muito
usado por temos que ir passa a estar por
cima do skate elétrico só saltar não
possa se for um bem vindo mas não todos
não para gravar para a criançada
agora não só o meu penteado a esse outro
comprar uma mega pisa para o documento
sim sim e sim fãs conquistam as meninas
pessoal fez um comida sempre sempre este
é o lema este é o lema de vida
a lista de dispensa cabeça corrigir meus
e foi cair e se machucar em chennai e
gela descobre que tudo o que cheire todo
o país pela tanto meus moleques mano os
filiados precisam ter mais amor deixava
o provolone melhor caio júnior da citada
no bom jardim muita coisa
depois de moré uma pisa vai gravar um
programa de humor foi como ficou provado
[Música]
[Risadas]
que é isso é normal eu to tv provocaram
direitos do frigorífico não me matou
a época que mais praticam bullying e se
lançar mão de usar não vai morrer se não
só sabe já não mata meu deus
a morte do esposo eo porto que conserve
o ela é o pessoal só temos de dançar
aqui eu não sei se vocês viram alguns
dias atrás mas o anti no canal de lança
um desafio e se viu implicado que
dançasse melhor que eu esse é fácil né
porque é bem gordo também sou mais
manjado words isso você já sabe o
pessoal que cuida da sarda sempre mal
méxico tem que dançar melhor que eu
tinha que me baby permissionário dessa
vez não só um pouquinho do vídeo eu
ainda sou o que exige uma semana dentro
do quarto treinar e fazer faça um vídeo
só dançar fui tão bem quanto eu não
esqueci eu não esqueci portanto agora
neste vídeo eu eu vou lançar melhor
portugal é só uma semana de treino deu
nisto
[Música]
vejam só esteve só levantou lei ou é
prensou a folha sol e ai ai ai
[Música]
eu não sei dançar amor à distância muito
grande parece muito mais porque ela é
assim
op a senhora do ó a mudança o é
olha aí o lançará a água toda saber se
você está aqui - a gente sempre está
sendo vôo ou eu só estou cuidado com as
luzes no céu europeu
[Música]
hum more parte nos jogos nós aqui sabe
dançar é na virilha não só eu não
esqueço que taxar o pisa visa chegar
calma calma posso afirmar que só para
ouvir a nossa dessa mesma 50 hectares e
melhor que o world communication pelos
três quebras e melhor o anfitrião
comentei mas que isso não vai ficar por
aqui né não sei se vocês sabem mas que
também lançou um desafio ao antes no
vídeo eu fui exportação e
consecutivamente enquanto lançou mão
deste domingo tanto a exposição também
mostrou do filme o que quer dizer que no
que mora o que vocês podem participar
neste disco solo aqui embaixo na
descrição vocês vão ter um entre lá e lá
tem todas as regras de como é que vocês
podem participar basta enviar um vídeo
com voz e dança de rua dança mais louca
e os amo vocês consigam fazer sejam
originais são muito originais
basicamente vai vir três vencedores o
antigo escolher um entre bill vai
escolher outro e eu vou escolher ou e
essas três pessoas vão conosco passar um
dia me importo nem esportes a ganhar
roupa progresso jogos é e vão estar
connosco portanto vai ter participação
olímpica em baixo e vamos buscar piso
agora tem muita fome
essa é minha casa
o youtube nós somos o oitavo e e criámos
nos dar uma prenda não precisa ler
nós não tínhamos nada vai mas só
queríamos dar uma recordação vocês se
poderem alguns de outubro se podia
mandar um abraço para oitavo e já vai no
olha que todos um grande abraço etapa
foi difícil agora valeu o piso é podre
espinafre não gostei
tomé não é muito bom sinal é muito bom
da equipe no período 10
assim ela minha filha não pisa não fazia
isso o japão nesta minha cama com um
copo porque sky 2001 visão é e isso é
ruim mas que ainda tocou em que não só
se forem nós aqui no canal inscrevam-se
vamos tentar chegar aos 3 milhões de
inscritos muito rápido e por que por que
vou lançar o como evitar uma namorada 2
quando chegaram os três mil inscritos
quanto mais rápido ficamos até essa meta
mais rápido e lançou o vídeo também bora
lá já sabem desse muito líquidos filho
pra vocês ficarem com uma amostra do que
vai acontecer pois não só que eu vou
fazer a catherine agora embora moroso
que aspira à china
então eu vou embora tinha até lá todas
usa moura ajuda a pagar estas boas não
chegou a esquentar a partir daqui eu
pisar aqui caiu né não
acho que voltei popular
não não tô fazendo mesmo tá e aí pronto
agora falta aquilo e neném n muito bem
empolgados bom e agora espera voltar
agora num jaguar xj em breve no canadá
mary mãe não o neuro câmera câmera e é
isso pessoal indica que o estúdio já
sabem inscrevam-se máximo possível vamos
tentar buscar os 3 milhões não luta se
humilhada não vou agora para poder se
inscrevam 3 milhões já sabem só ficaram
em us 3 milhões muito rápido e vou
lançar o resultado não é nada do que
escrevi